[SILENCE]
♪♪ ♪♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, WELCOME
THE YOU CANNER CARLSON TONIGHT.
THEY WERE TWO SPECIAL ELECTIONS
IN THE STATE OF NORTH CAROLINA,
BOTH OF THEM BILLED AS CLOSE
RACES LAST NIGHT N THE END
REPUBLICANS WON BOTH OF THEM AND
THEY WON HANDILY.
IN THE MORE COMPETITIVE RACE IN
THE NINTH DISTRICT DAN BISHOP
FINISHED SUBSTANTIALLY BETTER
THAN THE LAST REPUBLICAN WHO RAN
DURING THE MID TERMS, JUST TEN
MONTHS AGO.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL US?
TELL ON TWITTER THE DEBATE IS
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP ALWAYS IT
ALWAYS IS.
HOW MUCH SHOULD HIS RALLY
INFLUENCE THE JUT COME OF THE E
SFLEX NO QUESTION IT DID
INFLUENCE IT.
POSITIVELY.
HELPED THE REPUBLICANS.
BUT THERE'S ANOTHER FACTOR AT
PLAY HERE, THAT'S RECEIVED FAR
LESS ATTENTION.
THE DEMOCRATIC DEBATES.
THE DE BATH HAVE BEEN TELEVISED.
THAT MEANS THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY GETS TO HEAR WHAT
LEADING DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY
BELIEVE.
IT TURNS OUT THAT'S BEEN
TERRIFYING TO MANY PEOPLE.
WE GIVE YOU EXAMPLES OF THIS BUT
WE START WITH THIS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE DO YOU HAVE TO
SURVEY AT THE MALL, PARK, ANY
PUBLIC PLACE, AND ASK PEOPLE HOW
MANY WOULD YOU HAVE TO TALK TO
BEFORE YOU FOUND A SINGLE PERSON
WHO SUPPORTS GIVING FREE,
TAX-PAIR FUNDED HEALTHCARE TO
FOREIGN NATIONALS WHO SNUCK INTO
OUR COUNTRY AND LIVING MERE
ILLEGALLY?
YOU HAVE TO TALK TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE BEFORE YOU FOUND SOME ONE
IN FAVOR OF THAT.
ALMOST NOBODY IN AMERICA
SUPPORTS THAT.
AND FOR GOOD REASON, IT'S NUTS,
AND NOT SOMETHING WE CAN AFFORD.
nd YET ALL OF THE MAJOR
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES SAY THEY
DO SUPPORT IT.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO YOU WILL SUPPORT GIVING
UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE, IMMEDIATE
YOU CARE FOR ALL, TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY?
>> LET ME BE VERY CLEAR, I AM
OPPOSED TO ANY POLICY THAT WOULD
DENY IN OUR COUNTRY ANY HUMAN
BEING FROM ACCESS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY, PUBLIC EDUCATION, OR
PUBLIC HEALTH, PERIOD.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
HEALTHCARE IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> I THINK UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE
NEED TO HAVE A MEANS BY WHICH
THEY CAN BE COVERED WHEN THEY'RE
SICK.
PEOPLE NEED, THIS IS COMMON
DECENCY.
>> RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOUR PLAN
WOULD PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS?
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: UH-HUH.
IF YOU'RE MIDDLE CLASS PERSON
WHO CAN BARELY AFFORD TO GET
FIT, STRUGGLING AS SOME ONE TO
PAY THE PREMIUMS ON YOUR HEALTH
INSURANCE, IMAGINE WHAT THEY'RE
TELLING YOU.
THEY'RE SAYING THAT PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T FROM HERE WHO HAVE NO
RIGHT TO BE HERE, ARE BREAKING
THE LAWS BY THEIR PLEASE EVENS,
GET AHEAD OF YOU IN LINE?
THAT'S JUST THE BEGINNING.
ZARIOUS OTHER TIMES THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES SAID THEY
WANT TO PUT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CRIMINALS ON THE
STREETS.
THEY BRAG ABOUT DECRIMINALIZING
ALL ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSING.
EMBRACE THE FORM OF IDENTITY
POLITICS AND GENDER THEOLOGY.
THEY ROONTLESSLY ATTACK AMERICA
AS EVIL AND DESCRIBE A PERSON'S
WORK AS DE FIND BY GENDER AND
SKIN COLOR THE OPEN 1I689
AMERICAN DREAM.
THEY HAVE ENDORSED TAXPAYER
FUNDED ABORTION UP TO THE MOMENT
OF WIRTH.
>> SOME ONE ASKS YOU
SPECIFICALLY, SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
THIRD TRIMESTER ABORTIONS AND
YOU SAID THAT'S THE DECISION
LEFT UP TO THE MOTHER.
SO MY QUESTION IS THIS, I WAS
BORN SEPTEMBER 8, 1989, AND I
WANT TO KNOW IF YOU THINK ON
SEPTEMBER 7, 1989 MY LIFE HAD NO
VALUE?
>> OF COURSE I DON'T THINK THAT.
AND OF COURSE I'M GLAD THAT
YOU'RE HERE.
THIS IS A DECISION THAT NEITHER
YOU NOR I NOR THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE MAKING.
THAT'S A DECISION FOR THE WOMAN
TO MAKE.
>> Tucker: ANY DEMOCRAT AND
THERE ARE SOME WHO URGE THE
PARTY TO FOCUS ON THE PRACTICAL
CONCERNS OF MAINSTREAM MERGES,
ANYONE THAT SAYS THAT IS TREATED
LIKE A LEPER, UNCLEEJ.
THEY'RE MET WITH TOTAL SILENCE
OR WORSE GET A WLEK TUR FROM
ELIZABETH WARREN.
>> WHY DO DEMOCRATS WIN WHEN WE
RUN ON REAL SOLUTIONS NOT
IMPOSSIBLE PROMISES?
WHEN WE RETURN ON THINGS THAT
ARE BOURQUABLE, NOT FAIRY TAIL
XWHIX.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
ANYBODY GOES TO ALL OF THE
TROUBLE RUNNING FOR.
UNITED STATES TOWNS TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE REALLY CAN'T DO AND
SHOULDN'T FIGHT FOR.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Tucker: MOMENTS LIKE THAT
KILL ON TWITTER.
ALL THE TWITTER PEOPLE LOVE IT N
REAL LIFE THEY'RE A SURE FIRE
WAY TO LOSE VOTES.
AMERICANS DON'T HATE AMERICA.
THEY KNOW WE'RE NOT A RACIST
COUNTRY THAT NEEDS TO BE REBUILT
FROM THE GROUND UP.
MOST AMERICANS ARE CHEERFUL AND
MODERATE.
AND THE POLLS SHOW IT.
NPR PROL FROM TWO MONTHS AGO
FOUND LESS THAN 30% OF AMERICANS
WANTED TO DECRIMINALIZE BORDER
CROSSINGS.
41% WANTED TO REPLACE PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE WITH MEDICARE
FOR ALL.
A POLL FOUND ONLY 18% OF
AMERICANS AGREE WITH BETO THAT
ABORTION OUGHT TO BE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY REASON UP UNTIL BIRTH.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS ALMOST PERFECTLY IN
SIRNG WITH THE POPULATION OF
MARTHA'S POPULATION, MARTHA'S